academics to misinformation
foreign
okay
all right so I'm one of the organizers
Christian books of this Workshop or of
this program on graph limits and
processes on networks uh the other ones
are Jennifer Chase who was also here uh
Nicole emolica who is a Microsoft
research and I mean sabari who is that
staff
and I will this is a program which is
probably might be even more diverse than
our previous one we have mathematicians
studying graph limits we have
statistician estimating these networks
we have appearedologists we have
economists and there are some overlap
with the other programs or some of the
fellows sort of come to the
um
reading groups for both of them it and
so let me tell you a little what it's
about because some of you might not know
what a graph limit is so so what is a
graph limit so graph limit you can think
of Eisen object describing very large
graphs or as an object which generates
very large graphs
okay and one way to do that is you have
some function of two features and how
could that well you might be able to
guess can somebody guess who doesn't
know it how you would use a function of
two features
um
let me tell you that the function goes
into zero one so how I could use the
function of two features to generate
an intent graph
so either you know the features because
you're LinkedIn and you know sort of the
private life of everybody or maybe some
of these features are hidden so you are
you have some intelligence you're male
you're female you have certain degrees
you have uh maybe you have some hidden
qualities like local attractive your
writings are and depending on these
features two nodes will just connect
proportional to this function so this
function just describes how attractive
two features are to each other and then
you just if you know nothing you choose
ird random features and then build your
network on top of it and you make it
sparse by scaling this with some number
because if LinkedIn has 10 to say eight
members they're probably not 10 to the
16 edges in that graph
so you make its pass
okay and
how would you think of this object as a
graph limit as a whole Theory which and
we had the first Workshop half of it was
Mars which I will not go into but
intuitively it's very simple so you take
your large Network on endnotes
this is your student graph so these are
my students and these are their PHD
thesis and the first student reads his
own thesis the second gets told he has
to read to students thesis of the
previous student and the poor last
student has to read all the other thesis
so that's a half graph
and now I put this graph on a
checkerboard so I just put a white
square whenever I is connected to J so
one is connected to whatever 20 here and
so on
and then a limit you touch just the
limit of the picture okay
so if you take the limit and you squeeze
your eyes well in this example it just
gives a function which is one here and
zero here but in general if you squeeze
your eye it will not look that order so
you get a great picture
and that great picture is your limit so
in this way
you have for each coordinate X and Y you
get the limiting pixel density and that
is this function
okay
and so
um
and you can go back and forth between of
them so this is graph limits
now epidemics probably most of you have
seen this pictures which I took from
Wikipedia where
this is not from Wikipedia because of
Wikipedia I was not sure whether I'm
allowed to copy it so that one was one
I'm allowed to copy and you have seen
that okay but we all know that epidemics
actually have sets on networks and this
is what this program is so part of the
problem is about
so instead of having these differential
equations you have your network of
people
and everybody is in some State maybe one
of them starts infected everybody else
is susceptible and then you randomly
infect neighbors you randomly recover
and eventually when the time is over at
time Infinity everybody is recovered or
that depending on the disease
and so that is how you model it on a
network
and that leads to all kinds of questions
we are addressing this program right
different groups will have different
contact rates
individuals may be more or less
susceptible depending on age let's say
highly connected nodes tend to infect
more and tend to get infected more so
you have this complicated problem
on networks and there are many
interesting questions which we are
looking at
how do you want to underlie models
underlying Network
you take sort of talk to your
mathematicians that come up with all
kinds of networks which all look like
trees and that's not our social networks
um you want to predict are not either
from your model or you want to measure
this disease and predict what is or not
and you may want to look at the effect
of vaccination or social distancing
so and finally
what other things spread over networks
well we are interested here in economics
in spite of information on networks so a
simple example would be I advertise a
new iPhone I give sort of certain notes
on my Network's information about that
iPhone and then randomly they tell their
friends that they like the new on phone
or not that's very similar to epidemics
but maybe this is not quite how things
work maybe it's sort of you have to
convince me of something so maybe if 50
of my friends say something adopted
otherwise I don't so that would be
special at Moritz which are slightly
different from epidemics
and there are many related questions so
one of them I may come back to if I have
a minute which is uh you have some true
state of the world Okay so
you so Google will is us the next time
they announce earnings say we made much
more than last year or they will say we
made much less than last year and except
for the few Google employers here in the
room we all don't really knows it but
there is the truth okay maybe this is
tomorrow so it will they will either
announce this or that and now you have
agents on a network who gets some
signal about that perturbed
and now the question is if they're
taught to each other
can they learn the true state of the
world
are by combining their seconds
how do you do that do that do that in
some in rounds do you do that as a
patient who optimizes information there
are many ways how you can do that
um
and finally somewhat related is
the segregation models where we have
again a network people are neighbors or
not
and I'm happy if
at most 30 if at least 30 percent in my
neighborhood looked like me and I'm very
happy I'm in a diverse neighborhood but
if I'm just the only one I feel slightly
uncomfortable and move somewhere else
so
um
so then the question is will you get
Global segregation or not it depends on
the network depends on the starting
conditions so this is the kind of things
we study here with communities which
spread very widely
um
how much time do I have
30 cents
um
so let me just let me give you some idea
what we do let me do the next one now
let me do this okay so we have this
reading groups very Broad and we have
one one of the readings will be
discussed what is r naught okay so you
may have heard of or not it's sort of
the expect number of people who get
infected from the first individual ever
infected in the population
and it's supposed to be a number which
is smaller than one or larger than one
determined separate we all have seen
that
um so but it turns out that this is
actually a very complicated thing
namely if you just if you have a network
with hubs it really depends who you
choose if the first individual is the
Hub there will in fact a lot of people
and that doesn't mean that if this is
larger than one that doesn't mean the
epidemic will take off if you take a
random person well you don't have the
hubs that's not good either so how do
you deal with that turns out this
question we can answer
but if you have short Loops things again
sort of are really not true you might
think well if I noticed bigger than one
then in the next round I grow
exponential but if I have loops then I
try to in fact the same people in the
next round and so even though I'm not
this louder than one defined like that
you still don't get
an epidemic
and so maybe you should say in your
network households have a small short
cycle but maybe otherwise globally it
looks a tree-like so maybe we should
Define or not for households and it
turns out that you can do that and you
can Define you get an or not for
households and you get are not for
individuals they're two different
numbers
but in at least simple models they give
the same threshold so it turns out that
and our epidemic friends we thought of
this as a mask question but then and
statisticians really wanted to know that
because they said well how do we predict
or not and then our epidemics people
said well it's really not clear
it's an abstraction which probably in
reality
yes its usefulness is very unclear so it
may be sort of some nice picture that
you sort of you draw curves and it's
exponential you say you fit are not to
the rated which is gross and if they're
going down and that at least would have
this property but whether that has
something to do with how many people you
actually infect
is very unclear
so this is one of the discussions we had
in one of the reading groups with
mathematicians statisticians happy
neurologists
um
this one didn't involve economics that
would have been the other tidbit I would
have given you
know
trading our last speaker for this
session is also of UC Berkeley and he's
going to tell us about a program coming
up this summer here at the Simon's
Institute on analysis and TCS New
Frontiers
foreign
all right hi thanks thanks for the
invitation to present the program so uh
this is a program and these are the
other organizers of the program a
wonderful group of researchers so that
I'm happy to be part of
um so let's start with the program logo
this beautiful logo drawn by Barry bulu
care
um hopefully by the end of the tokyoles
and what's in this picture uh yeah this
is a program for summer 2023 about
Boolean functions analysis and its
connection to theoretical computer
science
so analysis of Boolean functions is a
powerful toolkit that have been pivotal
in the discovery of deep results in
complex areas of theoretical Computer
Science and Mathematics and here's like
a long list but it's not uh actually of
all the applications and you can see
also applications in combinatorics graph
Theory social Choice as well as other
areas in theoretical computer science
um and some of these results are you
know really pretty recent and there are
groundbreaking results uh very
impressive work
I want to mention that our aiming the
program is to extend this toolkit and
also to extend the applications okay to
apply it in other in other areas
but the connection between the toolkit
and the application is not necessarily
one way and it's clear that once we have
tools we can apply them but uh
oftentimes we see that the applications
themselves pose new interesting
questions and conjecture about Boolean
functions it turns out to be fundamental
questions that we didn't know before the
application and they are interested in
their own right one example comes from
uh the area of artists of approximation
that uh introduced this idea of
environment principle connecting between
analysis of over the Boolean domain the
discrete object analysis over the
gaussian
um so let me tell you briefly what is
the analysis of Boolean functions so a
key concept is the Fourier expansion of
a Boolean function we think of a Boolean
function as some function taking maybe n
input bit and outputting one bit
and we like to denote bits with plus
minus one for convenience
and uh very simple but very useful fact
is that every such Boolean function
every discrete object like that has a
unique
uh
multi-linear representation as a
polynomial so you can write this
function as a polynomial you have one
monomial for each subset of the
coordinates and the coefficient F out of
s this is just a real number this is
called the Fourier coefficient of of the
set s
and
and it turns out that this coefficient
captured very interesting properties of
the function that can be used in
particles that behave nicely with
respect to noise operators and with
respect to restrictions
let me give you one example so let's
take a very simple function the end
function
so the end function of two of two beats
recall that I'm denoting minus one as
true plus one is false
I claim that this function equals this
polynomial and you can check my claim
just go over all possible four right
inputs and check that the value of the
function equals the value of the
polynomial I did this check on the on
the slide
okay so so what did we get by that the
nice thing that we got is that we
express this discrete object as some
kind of uh polynomial over the reels and
this is now a continuous object so in
particular if we think of the function
as you know defining you know coloring
for for these four vertices where red
means
um plus one and blue means minus one now
this uh Fourier representation gives us
a continuous function so now it extends
to the entire uh you know continuous
domain in this case R2
and we can ask you know what's the value
of the the smooth linear extension on
the point 0.4 0.5 okay it's not a
Boolean point but we still get some
answer that has some meaningful
interpretation okay so this is just a
taste of what is analysis fooling
functions
recently we identified a few Trends in
in Boolean function analysis
so the first trend is uh go beyond the
Boolean Cube beyond the hypercube so
this talks about functions that are not
defined necessarily over plus minus one
to the end but are defined over certain
graphs or on high dimensional expanders
and these have been pivotal in a few
breakthroughs recent breakthroughs for
example this two to two conjecture used
heavily analysis of function over the
Grossman graph uh this is you can think
of it as some partial result towards the
unique games conjecture which is a big
open conjecture in
Antarctica computer science that would
explain a lot of areas of approximation
a phenomena
in another uh very exciting uh
developments we have with these high
dimensional expanders using them uh
recently this recent breakfast
constructed locally testable codes and
also Quantum ldpc codes
okay so this is the first grant the
second trend is going looking inside the
cube
this is a little bit like what we saw in
the last slide that the multilinear uh
extension naturally extend the Boolean
function to R to the N so you can also
think what's happening inside the queue
and once you do that you can apply an
arsenal of analytical tools on
continuous objects and you can think
what happens over the gaussian space and
you can apply tools from stochastic
calculus for example here you can see
that we're interested in this Cube that
has all these Corners that are colored
in blue and red but we can analyze the
the beever on the corners there's some
kind of continuous work maybe a Brownian
motion the sort of changes color as we
are getting closer to the to the
Corners okay so so it turns out that
this allows us to to to take a lot of
ideas from stochastic calculus and apply
them
um to the analysis of this uh discrete
objects and finally uh we have this
Landmark results uh about the capset
problem sensitivity conjecture the
kankalai conjecture and the sound of our
Lemma so now a lot of them are just
theorems and not conjectures and uh
maybe a common theme to all these
structural results is that they sort of
show the functions
that have a specific structure in one
aspect in one measure also have a nice
structure in a in a different measure
for example sensitivity conjecture shows
that functions that are smooth locally
mean that every the value of the
function is similar on every point in
its neighbors they also are simple
globally they can be represented by low
degree polynomials or by shallow
decision trees
okay so these are the recent trends that
we will highlight them in the workshop
we have one workshop for the first
topics and one workshop for this topic
um and we also listed some motivating
questions
that we haven't solved yet and we would
like to make progress on in this program
uh we hope that the critical mass of
researcher in this area would help us
make the the the necessary uh
advancement on these important questions
so one of them is indeed this unique
games conjecture that I mentioned
earlier well we already seen the
importance of free analysis in the 202
conjecture and we'd also like to extend
uh free analysis from Boolean functions
to high dimensional expanders and some
work has been done in this direction
uh certain barriers in circuit or bonds
might be surpassed if we we will be able
to analyze the Fourier spectrum of these
circuit clusters for example with the
constant depth circuit with parity Gates
and we have some specific conjectures
that we believe are true
and
also uh with respect to the
randomization and pseudor Randomness uh
a Hot Topic in recent years has been to
show that you can take any algorithm
that has small space and it's randomized
and you can remove the randomness from
it without changing Space by much we
don't know this yet but we have several
milestones we achieved several
Milestones toward that and we hope that
you know putting researchers on this
topic would make us make the next move
and some of these techniques here are
fully analytic and some come from uh
surprisingly from laplacian solvers
which is kind of interesting and finally
we listed some structural conjectures
that are still open
many of them arise from the application
like applications in communication
complexity learning theory or Quantum
computing and maybe let me mention just
this last one uh this aren't an advanced
conjecture sort of says that on a
typical input
a Quantum decision quiz can be simulated
by randomized definition please
and it has a so the question sort of
boils down to a very particular question
about low degree polynomials these
objects that I showed you earlier
and it has a very interesting new
application just this year to this
breakthrough result by Young how I'm
Jamboree that showed that if this
conjecture is true they are able to get
certified Randomness from Quantum
experiments from single
Quantum device okay so I'm
I'm done things
right so I guess we can ask questions
during the break we have a longer break
right now of half an hour so we'll
reconvene here at 3 10
um so I encourage you to ask the program
organizers more about their programs and
um at 310 we'll hear about from Natasha
Crooks also from UC Berkeley about the
algorithm Ace programs
I think I think
because because
for this question